in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode the
genius brain podcast you stinky useless
sons of [ __ ] I love you very much
well I have to be we're actually doing
the podcast without [ __ ] headphones
today because Sid is not so I don't want
to be the one that has it on as she
doesn't oh that's is that why you're not
wearing them yeah my wig I don't like it
I don't like listen by the way what is
the point because I get like feedback in
my ear so hearing and we're talking so
close together why do you need them what
it does is actually zones people into
the conversation I already have I can do
it I may be really focused on you in
this podcast I'm excited thank you for
having me no you know first of all like
I met you at JK news for the first time
how did you get invited on Jake Kane
using how did they find out about you
Nikki limo we were working together on a
maker project and before that I know
he's 14 cuz she did a series of mine
that I had on YouTube and she was really
sweet so yeah she hooked me up what you
said when she was 14 in 2014 you know if
we don't go that far back I didn't
wasn't in Santa Barbara but yeah well so
you guys met on that project together
how like I don't have that yeah
so I reached out to her because I think
I knew Lauren Francesca someone in the
YouTube community you know back in the
day we all kind of met actually maybe it
was Funny or Die I don't really know but
it was all Niki lemo we love her oh
really you're not even listening maybe
you need your head I am listening
I just wanted to make sure that we had
good audio on this [ __ ] because I've
done this multiple times where I've
recorded for two hours and I didn't even
hit the record button oh my god I've
done that too I've done that multiple
[ __ ] time game and then you try to
bring the same conversation back around
and then it doesn't I had to do that
[ __ ] with my best friend because I
forgot to hit the record button and then
we were here we were chopping it about
chopping it up about like our past like
it like we were in high school and stuff
and then we had a [ __ ] get lightning
in a bottle again and that [ __ ] was so
much funnier the first time around but
people loved it either way but you guys
should have heard the first one it was
way [ __ ] but I hate that it's like a
joke dying you know literally you had a
whole series of jokes die no straight up
and then he was like trying to recreate
as I bro let's not even try to recreate
it we gotta just talk about some new
[ __ ] because I'm just gonna get sad yeah
as a funeral it was a funeral wait so
are we rolling
we're rolling were rolling we're good so
you're not even [ __ ] listening did
you see that [ __ ] the levels are perfect
do you have three outlets what do you
mean oh because is it there Mike right
there oh I'm so I hope you hear that
conversation by the way I don't edit
[ __ ] so whatever you say it's gonna go
up on the podcast so be careful with
what you say here yeah I feel like I'm
the only podcaster that never edits any
other stuff the amount of work that you
and thought process that you have and
preparing for your podcast is
extraordinary [ __ ] zero but I put too
much time into my well I've done
podcasts where people are like hey like
I want to come on the podcast but you
know I don't want to talk about it I'm
like that's fine I was like but you do
know that we have one camera and we
don't have we don't do multiple takes so
if you feel like you're somebody who's
constantly afraid of speaking your mind
this is in the podcast for you
good for you to tell them that and me
now that we're on air and rolling well I
already saw you on JK news and we
already did a JB's together so you don't
need to be [ __ ] prep I know I think
you were so funny years you were my
favorite person I've only done it three
times but you were my favorite person to
work with on JK yeah and then you left
thanks no JK knees was a it was fun
while it lasted and I did it a lot
longer than I thought I was gonna do it
and then you know I've talked about it
on a video before but the reason why it
was hard for me to leave because number
one I was very comfortable with it I got
to hang out with my friends every
[ __ ] week but the problem with that
is that when you're comfortable you
don't really reach for more right and so
you know it was a good check I was
chilling with my friends all the time
and I just got too comfortable for like
a whole year I was just sitting there
just choosing not to do things because I
would have rather done JK news and it
was like well you got bills to pay [ __ ]
I know like what the [ __ ] are you doing
like yo you got to wake up and you got
to start moving and doing you know
things and I started letting go of my
personal identity and my own personal
brand not because they asked that was my
choice it's just cuz I was happy right
and so when you're happy you're
complacent when you complacent you don't
work hard right and so I made myself a
lot more uncomfortable I was like you
know what I got to cut the [ __ ] out but
it was hard because there wasn't a
replacement for me and so I well there
is no so Steve came on and when Steve
and I started working together I was
like I can leave comfortably knowing
that Steve's here
because Steve's a comic and so when I
went Steve had great chemistry I was
like I feel like if I left Steve could
take over and he'll [ __ ] smash yeah
and he does like kills it every [ __ ]
time so honey when Steve came in
I felt I felt less guilty for leaving I
was like oh so when Steve Steve actually
made allowed me to make the bigger move
and finally leave because like having
his presence on JK news is so [ __ ]
good yeah so it's like oh when I saw him
work on camera it's like I I can bounce
and it would be kind of cool so there's
no like gaping hole there so when Steve
came in
Steve kills it on the comedy he knows
how to like lighten up conversations he
[ __ ] kills it every time so yeah it
allowed me to break free and then go
back into doing my own thing again yeah
and so how are you enjoying it it's good
man I mean you I mean definitely when
you focus on yourself you make way more
money you know it's because like it's
like I said it wasn't because they did
anything it was I chose not to it's like
right well it's because of what I said
to you about the sex dolls that's what
made you leave ah you read too much in
comments I told you in the car I was
like I just I don't have a consistent
YouTube channel anymore so I'm just
curious of you and there's some funny
jokes in there of what people say and
there's the mean stuff too but they
inspire me to write different characters
and I'm just fascinated by it well
there's this one they kept talking about
me having like a TD or ADHD and I just
thought that was so funny and I don't
want to say what it is because I want to
get away I want you to see it when it's
on my Instagram but I wrote a little
skit about it that's gonna come out next
month let's go look out for that I feel
like you don't have ADHD or a DD I think
it's you're like do you and I'm just
like sick yeah yeah but you got a lot of
problems I am so man I have pieces of
complex PTSD which sucks with you
it's post time at post-traumatic stress
disorder I'm already getting it right
now so um I went through a lot of trauma
and so basically what happens is you can
get flashbacks you can it's not the
cutest look it gives you a lot of
anxiety
you can ruminate all these different
things happen but I go to therapy
I do EMDR I work EMDR is eye movement
just it's a long they're beautiful
damnit that's not even it I don't know
how to say it because it's a P instead
of an R it's something for your [ __ ]
brain you may edit that out
know that she's going right right
obviously I'm not a therapist or a
doctor but what is good process of what
it does is it it takes the trauma so
your pathogens in your brain are on the
wrong they're askew and you need it like
replace all of them I am so tired I'm
not even I did a whiskey pot gas before
that so this is like making me anxious
[ __ ] how do you not know what
EMDR before first of all said who the
[ __ ] cares nobody knows what EMDR I
wouldn't do it if I didn't know but what
it basically does is it helps you heal
your trauma okay and it places all I'm
making you anxious and uncomfortable so
right now you are you you okay
okay let's just start this right now I
need you know David does this he just
did this because I'm trying to listen to
you no no no you don't do that first of
all number one you just looking at my
that's just a regular asian face your
eyes are small and you look lost I'm
like that's just the face of Asian
people are you you said you put makeup
on for me I do this is I told you I'm
actually white if I take this office
just blonde hair you got my wig on
earlier and I was like your whatever
yeah it looks like a rat don't I know
it's this place I grew up in a wig store
do I see people without wings all the
[ __ ] time if you don't send me photos
of you at your parents would store in
Saks also you want when I'm there I got
your number now so random [ __ ] with me
in a bunch of wigs I would love that you
would look so good in a pink wig with a
pizza you know it's funny because I
grown up in a beauty supply store stuff
like you know people have like these
this perception of you know what
manliness and whatnot is but because I
grew up in a beauty supply store I grew
up around a lot of [ __ ] women yeah
you know what I mean so like I used to
do my mom's nails in the store I used to
like well [ __ ] wigs and [ __ ] but
nobody made a big deal out of it come on
so you wanna do my nails I'm like yeah
[ __ ] yeah mmm and that's just [ __ ]
hard man especially not to get you know
cuz like if you put too much it kind of
bleeds over into the crevices and the
gels up I hate that [ __ ] so I would like
I was so OCD about it when you [ __ ]
get mad I would take the acetone out of
wipe it off and I would do it again and
did you um did you ever get into sports
or were you busy with that no basketball
I did all that [ __ ] did you really I
when I was twenty I do my weight I now
know yeah
think like it's just like what that type
of stuff is encased in kind of kind of
influences what you think like manliness
is right because parents that men never
made a big deal about it's like Gil
we're in a beauty supply store he's
bored out of his mind what the [ __ ] else
he's supposed to do yeah you know so
I'll just be like hey you want details
I'm like ooh and I remember when I found
out that you didn't have to use like
nail we call it that the gloss the clear
coat buff that [ __ ] sometimes so I would
just be like buffing my mom's name [ __ ]
oh my gosh you're the best son I wish I
had a son that would buff my nails yeah
that's why I like I think people got a
little confused when they thought you're
gay I don't know what people thought I
was gay because I didn't this is how I
spoke all the time it's just like you're
an abuse apply so that's all I had to do
what else was I supposed to do there was
no TV there play with Dinosaurs or
something I don't know that's kind of
boring
I sit there just do this [ __ ] and you
got to talk to people cuz you're a very
bubbly kind person you like to engage
with people you know that and you know
for me to like it was just it was the
thing to [ __ ] do what else was there
to do besides play with the [ __ ] wigs
and the nail polish that's what we had
that's all we had there so yeah just do
that [ __ ] but then nobody ever made
comments about like you know that's like
some [ __ ] [ __ ] or whatever but never
they never said that to you I guess I
was a kind of maybe they did maybe I
just didn't care what have they said
that to you now maybe I don't know what
are they gonna say no that's some
position I guess no no one's ever said
that to me what they do is just say hi
that's so cool though I wish I I had
more guys around me that were very
comfortable in that situation because
most guys last time I went to the nail
salon which speaking of I asked you this
question in the DM and I will I want to
know the answer I am very curious to
know the answer to this David what oh
they don't remember it was your name
thing why why is that you know what I
think it is I think you're paranoid I
don't know no it's like I don't know if
it's because of the language is in the
middle of the mouth in the back of the
mouth when you speak I just think you're
being paranoid
because there's literally no [ __ ]
okay every time I called a nail salon I
guarantee you they like I say my name
Sid and they go see I'm like no no no
Sid it's just cause I can't pronounce it
and they and then I
say Sydney and they go too funny and I
might know they can announce it I know
but like they look when I'm there I'm
gonna do a walk and they don't like it
look I'm saying we're analyzing
everything you know what I mean you guys
what you need to do is smoke some
[ __ ] weed I don't know you want to
know I get worse
what about CBD with no THC no TV yeah I
can't do it before before I like spar or
I do stuff like that I take CBD drops it
helps you know relax it's good for like
anxiety I like I like wine for that yeah
but this doesn't have any like luck it
like you know like [ __ ] crazy effects
so like CBD like you'll just feel
yourself like chilling out a little
bit's like oh like there's no like
psychoactive fit there's no THC yeah
yeah yeah I like see I used to have this
one really good I forget the company
name but it was so good it tasted like
vanilla good yeah you're so funny dude
like you thought that because that's
just I'm not being able to pronounce
your name well no you call and you make
an appointment for Sydney and they're
not gonna like they are like honestly
there's something going on like
phonetically I want to know the answer
because there is an answer I'm not being
racist I really don't want to say you're
being racist
they just can't pronounce Sydney that's
all you're trippin yo chill out I have a
lot of stress in my life okay David you
know I know you got your s I'm a stress
ball right now listen my biggest thing
is to with people like there's there's
things that you can control and there's
things that you can't control everything
you can't control let God be with God I
know yeah I mean I think that's hard for
a lot of people though and this it's
hard for me too I just I just I hate
stressing out about [ __ ] it now it's
just it's not worth it yeah I'm 32 next
year's 31 no no oh and your birthday
March 30th Oh theory so it's like what
was that mean haha wait why are you
reading my face is just a white girl
face off into the distance and if you
were gonna go to a music video
are you talking about I'll just
observing what you did
what you believe in all the logical
Sciences [ __ ] well usually I don't like
Aries guys I don't believe in it but
like for some reason Aries and I don't
get along but not with you you don't
seem like an Aries nice to the max dude
are you really Aries you're the only
areas I like I'm pretty sure you'd like
some Mary jeez don't mother I really
don't like that you don't like it my
sisters and Aries my dad's an Aries are
two days apart and they're like
personality is like identical they're
usually super selfish which you don't
seem like you're selfish on that yeah
sorry for all the areas listening you
don't it's not that you dislike Aries
you dislike your [ __ ] family I know
it's probably what it is but I guarantee
you all of the traits go back every guy
that I've ever dated that some areas
they're all like that oh really yeah I
mean Joe Joe is an Aries this girl Julia
have you met her I think she's an Aries
as well she's also part of JK maybe you
just know nicer people I like to keep
nice people around me man that that's
what it is and the funny thing is like I
I think people I think you know if I'm
cool with you I'm [ __ ] cool with you
I mean it's just like there's like maybe
a small select amount of people I really
[ __ ] dislike and it makes it's my
mission to let them know I don't like
you you're that guy that you need to
tell them that you don't like well it's
not even that it's just more like I
can't pretend to like somebody if I
don't like them and it's like there's
only it's like a small percentage of the
world I don't like just because
everybody's [ __ ] up and they got their
own personal issues yeah yeah it's so
like for me I'm trying to as an adult to
really understand people and see what
they go through because every nobody
just turns out to be [ __ ] up yeah
there's always something that happens
when they're younger and for me what I'm
finding out a lot of people's parents
are [ __ ] these kids up they don't
know what it is until they get older
till they go through some therapy they
talk to and they go oh the reason why I
react is because when I was a kid this
[ __ ] happy yeah so I try to apply
that empathy to a lot of people yeah
obviously in comedy I don't because I'm
just making jokes ya know on a
person-to-person basis that's what I try
to do so the people that I really
dislike I can't even do that for them
it's like you're that people that you're
that big of a piece of [ __ ] oh my gosh
are you the guy that like when you're in
the room
with them do you like talk and like kind
of project that or do you get quiet no I
let them know okay I'll be like well
sometimes you can let them know with
like your look you know you don't always
have to like but I get quiet I'm like a
golfer when I'm not mad and tell I like
that [ __ ] dude yeah you could like see
the vibrations of anything or come off a
girl when they when they're like that oh
hey how's it going you know yes I can
give you a look that kills like you so
you're the guy that says some [ __ ] well
it's because I I'm I don't want to be
passive-aggressive look at them I'm like
I don't like [ __ ] are you doing here
that is not passive-aggressive that's
like that's like aggressive you know
like for example there's this guy that
kind of kicks it with a bunch of my
friends and it's this group of like
Korean dudes and we like a few years
back I used to drink a lot you know just
cuz like I'm Korean k-town you just
drink a lot of [ __ ] like that is that
right thank you my people love drinking
really we're like the Asian Irish no
just as angry drink just as much so we
get smashed or whatever but this is one
cat that always kicked it with us that I
don't [ __ ] like and I've literally
told them explicitly I don't like this
guy specifically because he's somebody
that's a moocher I hate moochers I'll
say what was it about him that you don't
like cuz you seem to get along with
pretty much yeah I mean he's a number
one he was a moocher so he likes to
leech off of people a lot and he only
develops friendships and relationships
off of people that he could gain from
and I hate that about people like
[ __ ] snake I don't like snakes like
you earn your keep around people
everybody's working hard you work hard
with them you don't try to like jack off
of everybody success to say it your own
yep I don't like that [ __ ] so even the
people i he was he was with like a
really close friend of mine too and she
[ __ ] loved him for some [ __ ] god
knows reason dude like she knows I
didn't like him because I was super
disrespectful towards him all the time I
told I couldn't help it I was like well
when he stops being a loser and he gets
a job sauce taking your money then maybe
I'll be nice to him oh he's taking her
money too
he didn't work for like a few years and
the dude like thought he was so he
booked like a very small role in
something right because now he's a
[ __ ] actor right and as a writer or
an actor now what's a small role he
dumps her cuz now he thinks he's gonna
make it doesn't [ __ ] make it he comes
crawling back she takes him
Oh [ __ ] trash yeah but you got to look
at your friends who'd be like girl wake
the [ __ ] up well I could talk to her as
much as I want and you know she has to
wake the [ __ ] up but her doing that
doesn't make her a bad person yes the
bad person yeah so her she just needs to
deal with her [ __ ] yeah but for him so
like any time he came by you know people
are like you Dave tried to be nice to
him I I can't I don't respect the guy I
think he's a [ __ ] trash bag and so
the last time I saw him we were at a bar
together and he was here and like the
tap you know we were all buying drinks I
was like yo it's like he was like Oh
drinks on me I'll say what you got money
now people are cracking up cuz they know
him and then he sits down I was like no
sit at this table go sit over there oh
sure yeah was because he always comes
out to me like we're chummy-chummy like
we're he's trying to be best friends
with me and I'm like you're not a good
person dude yeah like you've left
somebody because you thought you you
were gonna make money and be better so
you're only keeping her around as a
paycheck like I know this about you you
know what I mean I was like she's so
madly in love with you she doesn't see
it but I see it yeah yes what happened
he booked something else then he's
[ __ ] pounced on her again again but
wait there's not that much money to be
made exactly that's how much of an idiot
he is ok the dummy okay so it's like
I've literally like those are the type
of people I really let know that I don't
[ __ ] like you and also he's trying to
be friends with me because he sees me in
this like YouTube space and I'm writing
so he wants he's like oh if you ever
need an actor he says that to you and
[ __ ] like that it's like you know I mean
it's like you'll be at least like subtle
with this [ __ ] number one we're not
friends I don't like you like that who
is this guy like no don't give him a
name but I'm just like what like where
did he come from I I don't know too much
about him aside from the [ __ ] you
know shitty interactions that I've had
with them so he came in to click because
of the chick
yeah and he's just been doing that since
day one and I remember I met him before
they got together and he was just that
guy that would follow like youtubers
around and I tried to like be best
friends with them you know like yo this
is my homey it's like I'm not your homey
I don't even know you like that yeah you
would use like verbage and stuff like
that to try to get it get himself ahead
ok I hated I hate those type of
behaviors
same so it's like you're a piece of [ __ ]
don't ever [ __ ] talk to me so yeah
passive aggressive is it's something
that maybe I might have with my fiance
what passive-aggressive is not something
I have with people I you know like that
yeah the [ __ ] would you like that I I'm
thinking of the people that follow you
around at VidCon and that's like who
those guys are winding me up in my head
I've never been to VidCon before not one
I don't like [ __ ] like that
why do I like social exactly I don't I
should like that oh yeah let's see you
as but you do okay I get it it is
practice so like I talked to them about
this on the podcast before I had to
learn how to unfuck myself it's a hard
process so you know when when people
tell me is like I am anxiety I can't do
this I was like I guarantee you your
anxiety was nothing like mine I was I
had so much anxiety like I couldn't even
order food and I McDonald's or a Burger
King because I had to talk to somebody
anxiety I think like as a kid I couldn't
make eye contact I couldn't order food I
couldn't order food at a restaurant I
couldn't get anything for myself because
I was so afraid to talk to people aside
from my friends I was a goofball but
when it came to meeting a stranger it
would [ __ ] shut me down and then and
when I when I became like 14 13 around
there I started getting upset at myself
that I couldn't do basic human
interaction because of this I didn't
know he was called anxiety I didn't know
that what that [ __ ] was I just hated
this quality about myself so I started
forcing my stuff to to be in
uncomfortable situations it's like you
go and you [ __ ] or this [ __ ] food
you little [ __ ] ass [ __ ] is a [ __ ]
taco from Taco Bell just [ __ ] order
the [ __ ] oh my gosh is that when you
were watching Dave Chappelle so you
could imagine a how hard it was for me
to perform music and you know do
stand-up yeah I said [ __ ] it let's go
let's see this [ __ ] I remember I was so
nervous I could feel my stomach turning
my stomach I can feel my like my my
heart turning my stomach like it
literally felt like my heart sank and
just fell to the middle of my gut and
was the boiling an acid like that's what
it felt like doing stand-up for me and I
would grab at my pants cuz I was so
nervous I was Sadie's joke superfast and
I had to learn how to unfuck myself from
that [ __ ] so I did it over and over and
over and over until like I got to the
point where I can mentally prep myself
the day before and then perform standeth
wow that's a lot yeah it takes a while
man it's it's it's a [ __ ] process I
guess it's like exposure therapy or some
[ __ ] yeah I know it is know that I do
the same
when I did stand-up it I felt literally
the first show I got cottonmouth on
stage I was like yeah yeah like even now
like I did like a couple of shows that
my friends saw and you know it did
really well mm-hmm
but he was like yells like yeah I never
saw you do stand-up before because I
haven't really performed stand-up in a
minute yeah it was [ __ ] hilarious
like I was dying laughing he was like oh
how did you prep this like I it's just I
just go and do it now I was like I've
done it for so [ __ ] long I don't know
if I'll do well you know I just you just
happen to catch me on a good day you
know like cuz I still you should still
get those nerves ooh
but it's unhealthy that's why it quit I
just have to do this thing where I just
tell myself you're not gonna die what
the [ __ ] is gonna happen that's actually
not that bad advice yeah go up and if
you bomb there's [ __ ] professional
comics now that bomb doing their
stand-ups it's because they're working
their material out yeah you have to not
be afraid to fail which is hard
especially when you're like you knows
tip tone in the game and you're not like
fully in it you know I'm not even gonna
lie it feels terrible when your jokes
bomb hey walkers and nobody laughs and
you go [ __ ] you know like you hate
yourself a little bit for it yeah I have
been like whoa I still think it's funny
let me try it again
yeah and it still doesn't hit I'm like
we're throwing that joke away and then
maybe we'll rework it or something you
know it takes time but they kill the
babies yeah it's it's hard man it is
because you you said what you have
anxiety and [ __ ] too so how do you deal
with it
I just I keep going I put one foot in
front of the other even when I am dying
literally nobody would think you have
anxiety because you're you perform you
know you put yourself out that you tell
all these personal stories about
yourself didn't you hear me over explain
everything that's an anxious trait in a
human being if you've ever heard one
okay a lot of people are like that here
though in this city oh I know
um I I guess i overanalyze a lot of
things and I can't really shut the [ __ ]
up
it's so annoying can you imagine me in a
relationship I'm saying but I I try to
ground myself so when I'm get to a place
like that I usually have a piece of
jewelry on or like I you know remind
myself that I'm here or I look and it
sounds so crazy but every therapist will
tell you this I will
look at something like oh that's a piece
of art in front of my face it's blue
look at the other one it's pink just to
bring me back into where I'm at in the
space here yeah cuz I'm like either
future projecting or I'm past you know
projecting and you just want to be in
the now because that's all you can
really be yeah that's the hard part for
a lot of people because it's always like
well what if this what if that what if
this what if that I can't do that [ __ ]
anymore it put me in such a weird head
space and we all go down our little
spirals you know we all have it but it's
just good to have tools to get you back
into everyday like I I walk and the
reason why is because I literally blank
the [ __ ] out really like if I when I do
these walks they're like three or four
[ __ ] miles to the library no I would
go to the [ __ ] library these walks
and I it's like three or four miles I
blanked the [ __ ] out and then I just I
don't even know what I'm thinking about
I could catch flies in my mouth with my
mouth open
I I just black out that's good it's
better than like having a whole bunch of
whiskey and then I only drink for like
occasions so because I don't actually
like it when a substance dictates how I
should feel so it's like I want to be in
control that like if like if I have to
use this to feel normal I [ __ ] hate
it I am maybe it's because I'm a bit of
a control freak in that kind of sense
yeah I don't like when people were like
when I like weed I hate weed because I
can't I can't be present and say what I
want to say at the time I want to say it
yeah cuz it's always like I got this
funny joke in the twenty minutes past
and I'm like what happened yeah go I
wrote it down in the wall 30 minutes ago
let me find it yeah that's why I don't
really like weed and [ __ ] like it [ __ ]
me up thank you I love that you don't
like weed it's so nice to be around men
that don't like it cuz you even though
you're a weed pushing a little bit
earlier but it's fine I'm CBD pushing I
know
ways that you need a sponsor to have a
CVD sponsor you don't know no I don't
have a CBD sponsor but I love CBD [ __ ]
though I use your favorite company right
now I'm trying everybody and everybody
like everybody cuz I don't know which
one I like I just like CBD products I
just sense something movement [ __ ] I
just had in my head now I'm like I'm so
mad
I don't know I'm like bringing it back
and calling myself out now wait wait
wait AMD are reprocessing is the last
word okay
I didn't DS okay we're gonna Google this
give me my phone cuz I'm like so mad
that I didn't know what this was you
were talking about anxiety you giving me
my person it's like 75 pounds okay we're
gonna Google this and while we're
googling this I'm gonna have David rap
about his favorite flower
go for it David you promised me that you
would say this okay favorite flower
sunflower they were so happy they're so
tall and strong and they grow even when
the sunlight on them in the dark oh
really
eye movement desensitization gosh hair
weight reprocessing that's what's up
[ __ ] mouthful it is especially when
you have filler it's [ __ ] up do you do
you feel like like going to therapy has
helped you out the most [ __ ] no I'm
still [ __ ] up have you heard me spike
hello I need a lot more not enough I
started when I was five when my parents
were divorcing and then I got on ritalin
yeah cuz it [ __ ] me up it [ __ ] up
your brain as a child you know when you
don't have that um that family system
your you know families being torn apart
you don't have that bonding with with
both of your parents and it actually
changes the way that your brain forms it
changes the way that you respond to
people it changes everything
yeah so I got on ritalin and that's what
started everyone's like oh my gosh get
this [ __ ] off adderall and all the J's
ritalin it's the same thing as adderall
except it's missing one substance or one
element so it's basically I could tell
you this when I have had more sleep and
I'm working sorry I'm a little tired I
had to take two sleeping pills last
night because my dumb ass got on my
phone after I took mine here's if I
could give anyone life advice never ever
ever masturbate after you take your
sleeping pill because it's never a good
idea you will never go to sleep
you know I can't you know I like dudes
they always say like you should jack off
if you want to go to sleep yeah by
masturbate they keep me up really well I
I don't masturbate before I go sleep it
lets me it's not it's like hit or miss
for me but it's a huge miss if you have
a sleeping pill and do that because it
has the reverse effect really yeah
because it's like staying up and doing
something after you take a sleeping pill
it keeps you up it won't let you go to
sleep really I have no idea yeah yeah
well don't try it so that's my advice
take a sleeping pill get a lot of work
done I forgot what the other part was my
brain is like so dead right now but yeah
we were talking about like ritalin
trilling thank you do you want to know
what time we're at we're at 30 seconds I
never need to know 30 minutes we just
continue a conversation we just keep
going are you ready to end this convert
you want to end it now I can press the
button Oh [ __ ] lutely now you don't
touch that [ __ ] I will snap your [ __ ]
finger like a faux Japanese for fun
that's right look at that we teach me
something oh and save the cat I love
despise this is literally just for
decoration I haven't never opened up
that book before how dare you I refuse
but do you know a word in Japanese oh
yeah I my my fiancee speaks Japanese Oh
perfect she what is she she's Korean but
she lived in Japan and also Taiwan so
she speaks Mandarin Japanese Korean and
English I know so many people have gone
to Japan it's not fair look you should
it's [ __ ] dope I love the colors yeah
if you go to Tokyo you [ __ ] love it
she's wild yeah have you been yeah when
the Tokyo I've been to Japan two times
now three times you didn't learn
anything no language no I know I know
enough Japanese where if somebody speaks
it I can understand I just can't speak
it you can't say one damn word
everyone knows konnichiwa [ __ ]
why do you then why are you asking me to
say it because I want you to say let me
tell you something you and your white
privilege all right I hope I don't need
you dance for me Asian boy say something
in a Japanese [ __ ]
you know I actually really do like the
accent though the Japanese accent
I like the way it looks on paper too it
lets the prettiest language to look at
in the Asian culture I mean if you look
I think just so Korean is not cute I'm
sorry it looks like Japanese it doesn't
Japanese is longer lines it's prettier
buzz line line line creams are libraries
we're more stacked and it's just not
elegant it is stacked it's not elegant I
love that white privilege is coming
right in right oh that's [ __ ] Steve
green for you [ __ ] oh my gosh
that guy he's my white twist oh I swear
to God I just want to smack him every
time I see him he's like wanted to give
me a hug after we were done filming it
was like no hate yeah funny did you try
to transition this conversation David I
can't wait to see what you're gonna
transition I'm just using this time to
really get to know you as a person okay
well these are the problems that I have
I have a lot of issues I will be the
first to tell you well I mean okay so
you told me that you originally lived in
Atlanta then you moved here when you
were 16 you have great conversation
skills number one wait did you did you
move here to be in film and acting or
did you move here just because your
family moved here I got a scholarship to
the American Academy Dramatic Arts hello
I know it can do a lot of different
voices and stuff that's what I do and my
sister got a centerfold in Playboy who
does porn now and then Playboy's like
whatever nobody cares anyway
it's so weird that that like this is at
the same time I'm just like I'm eight
and then you guys all know yeah I was
always living in her shadow like I was
never like visible and social media
didn't wasn't really a thing myspace you
know there was no iPhone so when I got
lost I had a MapQuest map literally a
map in my car and I would call my mom or
my ex-boyfriend crying and because I I
didn't know where I was going so I knew
if I was heading west that was towards
the beach but you didn't really know I
was going south of I was heading towards
the hills if I was in like West
Hollywood yeah so
was like yeah we wouldn't mean by living
in your sisters shadow why because she
was a playmate yeah so like you know she
was like I was always the fat ugly
awkward kid you can witness and oh yeah
I was very overweight and then my first
trip out to LA actually was on the dr.
Phil show for being bulimic talk about
it
you were on dr. Phil yeah was on dr.
Phil dr. Phil's hilarious dude he's my
favorite guy the format completely
changed like the first you know it was
the first season was 2001 I sensational
value yeah now it's like more of like a
amore or whatever you know it's not like
the same I could have been they catch me
outside girl instead I was crying and my
sister was my sisters in my mom we're
all on there together those moods in a
wait that's what it was called the first
season and I loved Hollywood I thought
it was like the coolest thing ever and
then so spring break cut to like three
years or four years later my sister and
I come out here and we're having fun and
we totally sneak into the Playboy
Mansion because we were wild like that
yeah my mom was like passed out and
didn't know and it was just like it was
a lot of fun yeah well you saw you you
were bulimic I was bulimic yeah how old
were you nine maybe nine I think yeah my
dad would call me fat and like you know
say like you know that Park a commercial
and like I can't believe it's not butter
yeah it was like Park Hae or call me
Bertha cuz I broke the toilet seat and
he was just like he would be really mean
to me was he being me or just tryin me
funny and no he was he shut my sister's
face and dog food and gave her like
issues - yeah he just you know I don't
think you had good parenting skills so
that's where all of my issues stem from
okay everyone everyone know everyone has
the same reaction
well I'm sorry let's backtrack a little
bit
how do you think I'm funny David normal
[ __ ] aren't funny
no there's nothing funny about normal
[ __ ] a hundred I'm sorry you said
your dad you need a water suck your
sisters face in [ __ ] dog food what
cuz she wet the bed how does that even
how does that what called abuse it's
[ __ ] up yeah so but my mom like left
him because of all of that and yeah it
was crazy it was a wild situation I was
five so
would youwould like poke fun at your
weight all the time yeah and so I
started to throw up because I wanted him
to love me and I thought like you know I
could be skinny this way I don't know
where I was introduced to that idea is
still baffles me that I don't remember
but I just I was throw up too you know
when you guys were on the the when you
were on doctor filled and he was already
gone out of your life well my dad he'd
like you know he's a dad that makes the
appearances so like we would see him for
we'd get two weeks during the summer and
then that was it and usually we would
only last a week because my stepmother
was so awful and we'd always get put to
work on her horses or something else
like it was like a long did it mandatory
for you to see your father or is that
something that you guys wanted when we
were 4 2014 I could like decide to not
see how he decided not to see him yeah
so that was pretty much it but now I
mean we're as good as you can be my dad
you know I have to love him from a
distance it's very it's someone that you
can't get deep with it's very surface
it's a he is a narcissist and um you
know everyone's got personnel there's
one in 100 people that have a
personality disorder actually one in
five of the mental illness one in a
hundred that have a psychological
disorder where you could be a psychopath
a sociopath
you know cluster B or a or C uh in the
dsm-5 ooh hey a lot of [ __ ] I don't know
how you like saying all this way so
you're I mean that's so hard because
like I think as an adult and you know
like maybe it's like a coping mechanism
for us when we get older were like that
person that treated me like [ __ ] is like
that because something that happened to
him he wasn't given the skills to be a
good dad you know his parents weren't
great examples and he just you know they
were great at business and that was it
and he's a great businessman you know
but that's about it that's where it ends
yeah he's not generous because he's a
great businessman
can't be he doesn't know how to be a dad
so I've come to a place of acceptance
with that and it's hard the only thing
it's hard for me it's like I'll get a
text message for my stepmom and she's
like oh my gosh can you believe we've
been married 10 years I don't really
know her that well either but I love the
Christmas cards where she acts like she
yeah but it's all for show you know like
they just like to show that they are
doing well and stuff and so and that's
why I'm very honest and upfront and open
about all my problems because I don't
like to pretend that I'm this
happy-go-lucky [ __ ] I'm like no
actually this is what's happening with
me and if something recent happens like
what I told you earlier yeah I'm not
ready to talk about it till I process
[ __ ] yeah cuz it's so fresh like you
need a minute so like you gotta keep
things personal for you to deal with the
first before you do and you don't have
to say everything I know that we do not
know in there and there's like a certain
loyalty you feel like with your audience
that you need to share everything but
when you're not ready to talk about
something you and you talk about it and
we're talking about something that I
want to talk about so how did you how
did you kind of like kick the whole
bulimia thing I got lipo this
[ __ ] is hilarious funny dude
yeah never ever heard somebody beat a
mental disorder with life so how did you
defeat this meddler started liposuction
baby no but I was really committed I
tried everything I could under the Sun
like before that I tried dieting I tried
eating I spent all my money on trainers
because I would put any of my money
towards anything that I thought you know
and I'd go broke you know just to be
skinny to buy that dream and nothing
worked and so when I got married my gift
was the liposuction and that's the only
thing that was worth it oh my god how
much is a liposuction procedure it was
really good car it was really expensive
I don't even remember the exact numbers
but it was a lot yeah still that pricey
well I got laser lipo and in the
traditional lipo and then I did these I
went in a hyperbaric chamber before and
after so basically oxygenates your blood
and it's really cool and it helps with
recovery and I also stayed in an
aftercare facility because I was a
bloody mess so the whole process was
like the true did just for the lipo I
don't know but it was worth every penny
it changed the whole shape of my body
and it gave me that but mental
confidence that I always wanted because
this business tears you apart
you know you gained five pounds as a
woman or ten it shows on camera because
the camera adds ten pounds and people
are ruthless you have the recipe for
disaster to be in a business that tears
you apart mentally I know it's like but
you love it I don't honestly I might
take a break from it for a little bit
because I don't love it
I'm not haven't been auditioning I've
been going out I don't have an agent I
don't have a manager been a free bird
since the summer and I should out less
you - well it's not it wasn't really
like I decided to leave because it just
became an unhealthy work environment
because I was dealing with a lot of [ __ ]
with my ex-husband so the last court
date I had was in June and I got an
audition for SNL and I [ __ ] nailed it
but then I also did my first live show
and then there was some unfortunately
and I hate to like air [ __ ] out right
now but I we both decided it was time
for us to not work for with each other
but what made what hurt my heart and
I've never told this story before was
that she thought I wanted security
because I thought I sold out the show
and I was this hot [ __ ] but really any
time I do a live show I want to talk
because I did my first and she didn't
think that I could book a stand-up show
or do a stand-up show and I ended up
doing it in February of 2019 was she the
person that I was working with okay I
did it anyway I did the stand-up show
and then for the live show I wanted to
have my security just to be like safe
and know who was you know coming in
because I'm always scared that my
ex-husband or someone is gonna like come
to the shows that's always a fear of
mine when I do something live you don't
know my fans can be very grabby and and
so she thought that I was hot [ __ ] that
I thought too highly myself and it was
like wow I can't believe you think that
I mean when it's like coming from a
place of trying to feel safe yeah yeah
it's interesting how people perceive you
and it's it's good that I like knew that
no smart enough to like pay attention to
that because you don't want someone
that's working for you that thinks that
you think that you're hot [ __ ] or too
good for whatever like and they don't
know where you're coming from because
they're gonna sell you that way it's
hard because especially when it comes to
like like businesses [ __ ] a lot of ego
gets in the way so much ego um okay like
when I'm like the smartest things that I
always tell people I don't say always
but there's something that I've learned
too that I've learned along the way it's
like you have to really like partner up
with people that feel like they're
equal footing and equal ground with you
yeah like it's it's difficult
so sometimes too especially there's
anybody who's younger that's that's
listening to this [ __ ] you'll find your
place in very weird spots it's like or
if you do well people who naturally hate
you or just hateful human beings the
only way for them to be happy is if they
if you guys are at the same level if you
start if they sense that you're going a
little above them they want to drag you
down with them because that's the only
way we can be friends yeah it's like you
can't if I'm six if you're successful
well we can't be friends because now you
think you're better than me and not that
we think I'm better you should have grew
with me yeah I should have grown with me
that wasn't for us to grow yeah and also
be happy when if they're really your
friends be happy for them like don't you
know that it's hard for people though it
is but I like I'm always like even where
I'm at in my position right now like I
am sincerely happy for everybody that's
doing well I really am and I and some
people that I know that don't like me
and it's not perceived in my head
because I'm overthinking because I'm
still happy for them you know why you're
nicer than I am I'm too nice that's the
problem I'm too nice and it's a like I
need to get more mean but I just I'm not
that type of person I don't I don't know
I don't know if it's like me being I
just more like if if you wish ill upon
me I guess it kind of makes sense in
their head so I'm just saying like karma
happens it's okay sure my thing is like
if as it doesn't affect me personally
I'm like whatever good there's a lot of
youtubers that don't [ __ ] like me
it's because what did you do to them
data nothing I just have an opinion on
the [ __ ] and they don't they don't like
the fact that I have an opinion on the
[ __ ] it's like like I'll you know I'll
say something open it's like I didn't
really like that like will [ __ ] this guy
I cannot like your [ __ ] you sensitive
[ __ ] I didn't say I didn't like you as a
person I don't know you like that but
then you know people on YouTube who have
the kid audience oh you guys are [ __ ]
[ __ ] and [ __ ] yeah and the real
world's not like that people will have
opinions about your stuff all the time
if you don't want people to have an
opinion about your [ __ ] don't put your
[ __ ] out there you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's all that it is right so when they
put it out there and I don't like it
it's not my cup of tea it doesn't mean
it was trash it just means that I just
didn't like it yeah
movies and films on it that I don't like
that a billion-dollar blockbusters yeah
what the [ __ ] does my opinion matter
yeah I'm gonna take things so personally
yes so over it right now are you know
one person dislike what I what I made
I'm sorry you little [ __ ] yeah there's
a thousand more people like me my
opinion doesn't matter it's true it's
true I I heard your whole sensitive rant
with Joe and it was very interesting no
was because it's it's we live in a
society now where everybody has an
opinion and it's heard because of social
media you know a decade ago there wasn't
that platform so not everyone's opinion
got around as easily as it does now yeah
and it's unfortunate that YouTube is
censoring everything so much because
they're really taking away what they
created I feel like was a community of
like people that were making art that
were you know able to do whatever they
wanted and now it's so restricted I just
talked about that today to how much and
what people don't understand about what
I missed about YouTube it's not so much
I want to say it's like the content that
we grew up with but it was the fact that
any type of content was allowed right so
it's it's it's weird now where
everybody's content is either the same
and my escape from traditional media was
YouTube but now YouTube is traditional
media you can only you make this content
and this content if you say this you get
reprimanded and so the one free space
that we used to have has been taken away
yeah and I miss it a lot right so it's
like now I'm all my [ __ ] by the way when
this video goes up it's already monetize
I'm making zero dollars off this really
why don't you just put parts of it like
Joe Rogan does I do the part they're all
the monetize everything I make is
demonetized I don't make [ __ ] on YouTube
why did you get to monetize what did you
did you do because I curse a lot that's
all yeah that's it
so I curse a lot and I have opinions
about [ __ ] and then you know that's
that's really what it is I don't make
kid content and my demographic is a lot
older yeah so I know it's gonna get D
monetized and the D monetization isn't
the issue is the fact that because I
don't have add friend Lea stuff and I
don't make you know YouTube's machine a
lot of money yeah I should gets pushed
down people don't see it and that's just
is what it is I have like one point four
seven or five like million followers and
only a percentage sees what I make
that's it it's like like what Instagram
is doing out of the the platform and
it's really hard to like get the views
and get the
like that you used to get it happened
this is starting to happen recently too
because my friends were telling me about
it let it started happening on their
instagrams and it just happened to mine
recently oh yeah oh I was like why is
why cuz I don't really look at numbers
that much right but then my friend was
like yo man like did you check your
numbers recently like what do you mean
he goes like look at your post they're
not getting as much likes and views as
they were before I looked the analytics
it dropped like half I was like oh what
happened sponsors money like I'm like
why is Bernie Sanders in my political
like what is won't even follow politics
like I'm a political so I'm just like oh
my what is going on sorry if anyone
hates me for that I'm sure like the next
election I'll care more but like I was
dealing with the court system this year
and going through my divorce that was
enough for me like give me a break it's
crazy like once money gets involved the
platform changes and and I understand
too and I understand like YouTube's
perspective of like are you gonna take
talk I don't think so you should it's
fun well what is tick tock explain it to
me okay you don't know what tick tock is
I see it but I don't know what exactly
the platform is dancing I like seeing
people dance I guess but are you good at
dancing absolutely not that's perfect
okay
ironic okay okay do you like movies yeah
I love film do you like catch phrases
like what like anything from like your
favorite movie let's say like a Jim
Carrey movie or okay I'm like yeah yeah
so you could literally take Chappelle's
like jokes like your favorite jokes okay
and you can make a tick-tock of you like
re-enacting them and then edit and all
these crazy ways because they have these
awesome like filters and features and
it's so much fun it's so much fun sounds
like a lot of work it's really not
because all in the app it's not like
what it used to be where you have to let
go and it's so easy and you can even
upload like you can film the video and
then just upload it up - tik-tok of you
one so you don't have to do it in real
time and it's so much fun I just joined
tik-tok and I'm like obsessed with it
that's crazy cuz like I know I think
like so tick-tock before was musically
yeah right and I know like before that
it was another app because they were
trying to get me to like do sponsor
stuff on it but a big huge like Chinese
conglomerate bought it out so there's
billions of dollars backing this thing
right and there's actually money
involved
so like vines biggest issue and the
reason why vine disappeared
they didn't have they didn't have a
monetary platform built as a foundation
for it so there wasn't any muscle once
that VC money disappeared mine was gonna
disappear too right so but the
difference between that is tick-tock
even though is similar but better than
what vine is the difference is there's
money backing this so tik toks not gonna
go anywhere yeah the only issue is for
me it's just like I gotta get another
app it's it's so worth it cuz that's
where everything's gonna go because it's
not as heavily sponsored as Instagram is
because instrument basically sold out
when Facebook bought everything yeah for
sure
that's when you could start like doing
promos and all these things that change
the algorithm it constantly keeps
changing but oh now I just feel like
it's getting less and less and less and
less and less yeah like I'd like I
should really pay attention to these
numbers but I don't just because like it
stresses me out it's so stressful
because like Instagram is my youtube you
know what I mean so like I don't really
care about YouTube but I can imagine
that you go on there and you check that
[ __ ] out and you care a little bit not
YouTube I check numbers only if I have
brand news and I have to do it so the
reason why I don't do that and I don't
comment as much anymore it's because it
is not because I don't want to interact
with fans it's just more like there's
too much outside [ __ ] there's too many
trolls yeah there's and if I look at
numbers that I'm basing my content based
on what people want to see versus what I
want to create and so I can't do that
are you excited that they're gonna take
away all the likes on Instagram
eventually I think it's good for kids
yeah like I I really do appreciate that
for kids I don't mind it I'm not upset
at it and I need that for their mental
health yeah I don't really think it's
for mental health I think it's because
they can like control the sponsorship
and they can get the money like directly
from the people I think you do with
mental health but I think it's great for
for for young people to understand like
yo man you can't base your value on this
app through this number some other app
will open up and they'll do and they'll
probably follow it yeah but I'm glad
that Instagram doesn't have that feature
because like I know from my friends
who've had kids when they were younger
yeah they're kids like this they told me
that they're the most popular kid in
school is the one with the most
Instagram followers what yeah that's sad
but that's that's what is turning into
you know times have changed gosh what
are your kids gonna be into I don't
[ __ ] know I'll be like Chappell I
moved into a far more social that
actually doesn't sound like a terrible
idea I'm scared like I'm scared to have
kids but I do want a kid at Lee
yeah but I'm kind of scared to have them
yes because like I forgot what all the
time I mean there was this theory where
somebody told me like the reason why you
know even though there's a lot of dumb
people in the world they don't get to
rule everything is because for every one
smart person it equates to like I'm like
a million dumb people so it's like it's
like oh if I truly believe that I have
something to offer in this world then I
should be able to instill those values
into my kids yeah and like it sucks
because some of the most intelligent
most kind people on earth they don't
want a kid and I'm like you're the
people who need to have kids don't ya I
need you to have children because
everybody else just [ __ ] without a
condom they're popping out kids like
[ __ ] nothing and they don't care
about their children they're not
developing them but you I know if you
have a kid you would do that it's just
that you know they're there
analyzing things through numbers it's
like what's the whole point because the
tab will cost this much this much it's a
lotta they're not cheap children are not
cheap you know and it's a huge [ __ ]
commitment like every second is like a
learning experience for them when their
grain is their brain is growing and it's
scary like I don't know relationships
are work kids that work every time you
said you're going through a divorce
right now I'm divorced officially is my
yeah yeah I thought you were divorced
when you talked about on a news though
you were going through
I was I was officially divorced in
January of this year but I had to go
back to court for a stupid issue that's
been resolved it was resolved that day
and June this was this was the older guy
that you were with right
yeah the thirty three and a half year
older guy I was a grandmother I am no
longer a grandmother three children
33 and a half year old yeah I was 23 he
was 57 I got married within four months
of knowing someone as a way to cope with
trauma
my stepfather killed himself I was in
the next room and then three weeks
before that my grandfather died who was
like my dad he was always there for me
was my rock my stepfather worked as the
chief of homicide with my grandfather
because my grandfather was Chief of
Police and I remember my stepfather and
I he lived in the same apartment
building as my mom did when my mom and
dad got a divorce and that was the first
guy my mom dated after my mom's divorce
so like they dated briefly 97 and then
they reconnected when my grandfather had
his stroke by my grandfather's bedside
and then they just
to get married so it was crazy how all
of that like happens and wait your
stepfather what he said he was the chief
of homicide and then he was bipolar and
we didn't know it and he didn't take his
medication because he was manic on this
high you know marrying my mom and moved
out to California from Georgia and then
I don't know how many months went by
gosh May June July guys and four months
later he shot himself in the heart knows
my next room sleeping that's [ __ ] we
just got back my my grandfather's
funeral and it was nine days before my
22nd birthday damn what if [ __ ] rains
it [ __ ] pours yeah so and then like a
year cut to like almost a year later it
was August 2013 I broke up with my
ex-boyfriend who's also dead in July of
2013 because he just couldn't keep his
dick in his pants it was super hot he
was run over by a train in Burbank in
2015 he was filming a video I talked
about this on JK and they were like it
was so hard for me to like hear the club
because that's still something that's
like I'll never find funny cuz it's like
you know it's a it's looking back at it
it's funny to people that don't know him
but like it's not funny to me but um but
yeah so I broke up with him and then I
met my ex-husband in August of 2013 we
got married in December of 2013 for his
reasoning very romantic taxes cuz he
wanted to get married before the tax
here ended cuz he was a CPA so I was
like okay he was still married when I
met him and I didn't know what they were
going through a divorce and he also had
two other girlfriends Laird is higher
marriage yeah cuz I thought oh he's not
gonna cheat on me he's an older guy and
he would be love bomb me because he
wasn't a malignant narcissist which I
learned all about narcissus like dirt Oh
God the mask came off like a year into
our relationship so I kind of started to
see the behavior wasn't the same he was
changing what's going on I was getting
sick with infections that's when I
started I was like on antibiotics like
20 months out of like or just like
[ __ ] random [ __ ] yeah like ya know
like I said I get sex addiction he was
[ __ ] hookers like Street hookers you
know like it was [ __ ] up so like my
[ __ ] look like
the Grinch like I was like what the [ __ ]
like I was constantly in no the ER in
the hospital and he was like maybe
you're anemic maybe you know you're this
maybe you're that you need to go to a
different doctor so I went to like five
different doctors cuz I didn't know like
different gynecologist cuz he's like oh
that you know they're probably not good
I read the reviews on ball what so I
would keep changing I mean finally one
just said I was with my mom and my mom
had the you know a different brain and
being an older woman she's like why does
this keep happening her he's like unless
he's cheating on her there's no reason
this should be happening and then my mom
hired a PI and didn't tell me because
she knew that I would like shout outs to
mom yeah so she hired had him followed
for like three months
and then we were [ __ ] like after
Valentine's Day and he came home early
it was really weird for him to come home
early I was like this is strange and he
did a different sex position so girls or
guys if you're listening if your partner
changes up the sex position unless you
guys are watching porn together or
something that's kind of a tell and so I
didn't say that I don't know if I said
that directly in my mom I might've
because we're pretty close but I was
like something's off and I could cut
like women's intuition your intuitions
usually always right that goes feeling
something prior to that because it was
like to not like why was he always so
like nice like he's being so nice
he has no nut in his ball sack that's
why yeah exactly was free exactly so
yeah it turns out not only was the
mistress who is a stripper
EW working at his company but the porn
star that he was also [ __ ] that was
the other mistress was like everything
was taken care of she had a credit card
he had her all set up in addition to all
the other street hookers and he was
[ __ ] a hooker right before he came
home to [ __ ] me that day he's a true
addict yet he didn't think so how do you
nine [ __ ] like how much do well
you couldn't tell what he nutted and
[ __ ] just powder came out yeah no I
couldn't tell he was really motivated
but you know what's crazy like looking
back I even do nuts like four or five
times that [ __ ] [ __ ] is thin not when
you're well gosh this boy I don't know
cuz I always got sick so I never really
like paid attention you know I'm like
that wasn't like I was just always when
I was like having sex and was like
please don't get sick please don't get
sick that's all I could think about
that but it's good information I know
like wanna do nuts
you could just tell by the viscosity
it's like [ __ ] you jacked off a half go
so if there's a lot of [ __ ] there you'll
be like okay like I know you've been
waiting like so like this is this is
just general [ __ ] right like a dude will
usually like jackoff like maybe like if
they if he wants to [ __ ] tonight right
like wants to show you a good time yeah
and like I said it's not every dude but
if every dude doesn't do this you guys
are [ __ ] up if you guys like
premature ejaculate is because you're
[ __ ] holding all this come too much
so like dudes will like jackoff maybe
like the night before or like that
morning yeah and if you guys if you're
gonna [ __ ] at night so you could last
longer yeah first come load first of all
there's pre coming that [ __ ] yeah so you
got to make sure you [ __ ] jack off
then you pee then get rid of pre [ __ ]
yeah and then you last a little longer
yeah so if you if you see like a load if
the dude hasn't jacked off in four or
five days that load I should said some
thick [ __ ]
and the amount is a lot but that if you
see this then is hell and there's not
much [ __ ] coming out that means that full
[ __ ] jack off a lot that day [ __ ] I
guess when you're married you like don't
think about it like that you know what I
mean like it's just what before if like
I'm going out on a date with a new
person I actually masturbate so that way
I don't [ __ ] them but if I drink then
that's a new role for me I can't
remember the thing that you said in the
car earlier it was so yeah [ __ ] on
the first date is the thing I don't want
to be that person on the first date
oh it never works out you showing
everybody your hand in your car just
[ __ ] wait for that [ __ ] unless you
don't give a [ __ ] about that person it's
like exactly yeah Joanne is what I call
her a shady [ __ ] that one we do not
trust her so that's a new rule I have
myself I'm not ever drinking on a first
date are you pretty like hyper sexual
then yeah yes what then dude then she's
rough cuz like like I always say so I
just said like to old stand a bit about
this [ __ ] years ago where I was just
like I can't [ __ ] wait til the day
where I have no [ __ ] sex drive cuz
then I'll [ __ ] cure cancer the next
day cuz like I'm telling you like when a
dude nuts it's it's like have you seen
that [ __ ] like Instagram filter where
numbers just pop out for a split two
seconds on the smartest [ __ ] man on
earth dude all my life's regrets come
out where i nutted on it's like god I
[ __ ] nut it in that bitch's face and
that is so disrespectful but when you're
horny you're like but it's not place to
do yeah that's perfect
I'm into it I'm like sure my way of
hyper sexual though yeah it's I don't
know I'm not I'm not making assumptions
about you but a lot of my friends who
like females who are very hyper sexual
they have a lot of like sexual trauma
well yeah no [ __ ] yeah people are into
BDSM or I don't know this [ __ ] you know
until like I started talking to my
friends about their past and what
happened when they were younger and how
they view sex as an adult it's it's it's
hyper sexual I'm like yeah what the [ __ ]
happened yeah I mean reading all the
[ __ ] and like watching all these
documentaries I'm like that's why yeah a
lot of the times like it's hard for an
individual to say like oh that's the
reason why because it puts like a
certain event and it makes it too real
yeah so now it's just like no I'm just
like hyper sexual it's like no there's
difference like hyper sexualization I'm
only attracted to someone that I like
you know obviously I have to like I
haven't gone on a date in like six or
seven months cuz I'm like I'm just so
[ __ ] over it but for me to get put
all this effort and to go out on a date
with someone is a lot and I'm always
working so like if I want to waste my
time going on a date with someone I'll
probably block in three months anyway
that's that's actually a big [ __ ]
deal like I don't just go out with guys
every week and I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ]
you on a first date like I'm not I have
to care about the person you have to
like the person enough in order to like
want to [ __ ] them but once I do it's all
and I'll be calling you but it takes a
lot to get me to that point I know I
will go if I have too much to drink on
the first date which I don't do that
anymore anymore okay I swear to God I
believe you but I yeah once I'm like
into somebody I'm really into them and
that's something that like you find I
don't look at someone's gonna [ __ ]
that I don't want to [ __ ] a stranger you
know anyway that's like it's some dude
[ __ ] yeah that's very that's very like
male yeah I've not my brain doesn't work
that way so your your that's interesting
because I feel like maybe it's cuz I
grew up in a church setting right yeah a
lot of girls they weren't very open with
their sexuality they get so
uncomfortable and it makes me
uncomfortable yeah they get really
uncomfortable with it and I think that
was because I grew up in a church
setting right and so like some of the
worst sex that I ever had was like with
some church girls just because like in
LA it was either one it was like too
vanilla or
it's not a bad thing like I'm not making
any judgment that's their version number
two it was like they were always trying
to prove something so like the sex felt
very unnatural you don't mean it's like
Oh like they saw not that type of
[ __ ] girl you think I am but it
doesn't feel like natural you know what
I mean so I didn't really like it so and
that's just like somebody not being
comfortable with their body yeah right
and so when somebody was comfortable
with their body they're also come from
like confident in their movement and
what they do and how they do things and
it was just like and at the same time it
would be hard for me be like yeah you
know maybe like retract those teeth a
little bit why did you say that to them
I mean it obviously if we were gonna be
together for a long time I would but if
you're hooking up it's just like we
don't really need you know I don't need
to like you know then tell them how to
do something right maybe some guys like
a lot of teeth on give them directions
so that way they know they can turn into
like amazing some people would some
people would take it a little weird you
know cause like every all these guys
have gassed them up it's like a blog but
I'm the one it's like yo and I will hurt
their pride a little bit really good if
you try it like this
I told this story to like as a young guy
guys gasp themselves up so much about
sex like they think that their dick is
like the magic stick right yeah and
because when you're younger all your
homies talk about their [ __ ] sexual
escapades as if it's the milk it's like
yo man I [ __ ] bag this chick I got
this chick dude she was [ __ ] coming
all night all this other stuff right
yeah you know that's just a lot of
bravado yeah for for a majority of dudes
right and so for me going into it I
didn't know what the [ __ ] I was doing
and the funny thing is who does you know
as a young as a young male you're you're
scared to ask a female what she wants
because you're told in your head you
should know what they [ __ ] want yeah
so the the the moment I started getting
better at sex I'm not saying I'm [ __ ]
amazing at that [ __ ] but I asked a lot
of questions now because I find out his
preference yeah and so I remember it was
his girl that I was together with we
were like in a serious relationship for
weeks a long time yeah we were for me at
the time very long time and then we were
[ __ ] around but
right I asked I was like how was that
[ __ ] right she was like was okay okay
hold on a second
let me let me happy Wow right and she
goes okay well because of this this and
this is because she was very sexual she
was hyper sexual rain and so she's had a
lot of partners before and she just
started listening like well when you do
this isn't that it's not that great I'm
like well [ __ ] tell me yeah let's try
this I think that I don't know my
[ __ ] dick game was whack like what am
I doing wrong the way yeah you need a
little more foreplay you just try to
[ __ ] jackhammer me through the whole
thing and I was like oh this is like
when I was like 22 okay I know and I'm
like nobody [ __ ] told me this yeah
you know from that point I was taking
notes you [ __ ] I'm like oh okay ah do
that a little more foreplay you use your
hand you should tounge use all this
other [ __ ] mark yeah or you start
[ __ ] really hard and I'm like oh this
is what you're supposed to do yeah cuz
you know when you're a young kid you
know I the first I lost my virginity
when I was 18 and it was also to another
girl who didn't have a lot of sexual
partners so she didn't know what she
wanted I didn't know what I wanted and
so I just assumed that if you stick it
and it'll feel good but it's not there's
a lot more [ __ ] to that especially what
the person who's already had a lot of
sexual partners [ __ ] know so she was
my biggest life lesson when it came to
like being intimate with somebody seeds
when you tell them and you communicate
communication is lubrication oh I
[ __ ] agree that's why I always get
like confused when dudes are like you
know man like they whenever they hook up
with somebody they said like you know I
[ __ ] she was [ __ ] loving I was
like how everybody's he's a little
different
it is not everything works in the same
person there's no way that that specific
mood works for every [ __ ] girl that
you're with so what was it have you been
to a sex party
no absolutely not I ain't that freaky
though I'm like I like [ __ ] but my
shits not really up there like they're
not like having you just go there to
watch you know to do anything oh I would
just be like oh your social anxiety I
was a sex party what's that like I was
going to the Playboy Mansion you know
well there was happening there but um it
was a traditional sex party no but
there's this Dom who has like a
dominatrix that has a lot of sex parties
and she invites me all the time
yeah there are a lot of fun I just had
this girl my podcast who runs a bunch of
sex parties and they look really fun I
mean this is I mean you just have to
participate you can just what exactly is
a sex party
well there's you know different things
happening sometimes it depends on like
what who's party you go to there's
parties every week it's a whole
lifestyle but and I'm not really like
into it like but I think it's fun to go
like I'm single now so like I would go
just like have fun but I wouldn't hook
up with anyone because I just I like to
see people and their sexual element I
think it's fun there's a lot of
nakedness around and a lot of people
playing like for instance she has this
like naked Candyland this was like her
Christmas party and she had a whole
bunch of like naked elves and like you
know hot naked Santa's where you play
all these fun games and it was like
super sexy and I was just like oh that's
like I would want to go to that he was
like you know I'm a dude [ __ ] you know I
like sex and stuff like that but I don't
like it enough to go to a sex party
because probably your guy I don't know I
guess I'm an emotional [ __ ] - so like
I'm emotional that's what I'm trying to
get across earlier you [ __ ] like I
can't you're in a relationship
yeah so like I like I like sex is only
good for me if we connect you're like
yeah exactly yeah like I mean I'm not
saying I haven't [ __ ] somebody that I
didn't connect with that's because I was
going through a dry spell I just needed
to [ __ ] yeah it happened yeah but it was
never that great it was just more like I
just felt like I could've just jacked
off but instead I you know there's this
cute girl and for some reason she was
giving me attention and let's just let's
see what happened like let's do it yeah
you know what I mean I was a very
persistent guy - let me tell you
something [ __ ] I'm kind of fat but I'm
gonna put the moves on you well I was a
big guy I'm still a big guy but I was
like before I met you I was like 200 NT
pounds y-yeah so you had to you had to
have game I had to I to you I had to
[ __ ] use my mouthpiece oh yeah yes
you learned that was good for you though
you learned how to finesse and she was a
hard man yes I was [ __ ] difficult
that's why when I see like some
youtubers I hear these stories about
youtubers where they tell other girls
like I'm a youtuber to get them in bed
and the girls [ __ ] him because of that
I'm like you are the lowest [ __ ] woman
I've ever met in my life like that's
like [ __ ] as ELA celebrity dude I
know
but not that I'm saying like it the
rappers I had never liked the girls that
were the groupies of the rappers that
like really bothers me like I'm not
knocking on those chicks like you get to
you know [ __ ] your idol that makes sense
you know okay but if you didn't know who
they were and you [ __ ] them because
they were a youtuber that's a little
weird like I think like the whole like
the whole thing yeah like I like the
whole groupie thing is like oh you get
to [ __ ] with somebody that you've had
like an emotional connection with that
you never met so for them it's like a
different experience right so I get that
it's like if I followed let's say like I
don't know let's say like I wasn't in
the space right and I was like your
biggest fan ever right and you gave me
attention drink that [ __ ] up exactly it
is yeah yeah guys they want to put their
dick in anything
girls are like no [ __ ] funny stories
from dudes we're just like a couple of
YouTube guys above cuz we don't in yeah
we don't name drop here yeah well I
don't know Tim I don't know like Tim and
Annie is like well I mean everybody's
like [ __ ] groupies and [ __ ] like that
you know any youtuber that you know
whether it's Tim me or somebody we
[ __ ] a groupie before yeah so it's
like I want a groupie now dammit yeah
like like all due to [ __ ] I mean Tim
has probably told stories about on his
podcast me it was a lot of people have
done that you know cuz you're going on
as Tim is it's Erica yeah and so like
this is like back in the day before we
had serious girlfriends and Beyonce's
but I've like I haven't done this but a
couple of my other friends to FIFA they
told me stories about like groupies that
they literally were not attracted to but
they were just like I'm just going to
make them feel good
oh they really want to have sex with me
yeah I guess I'm gonna have sex with
them
gosh see I I can't think that way I
don't want to do that we could just
because like you know I've had cervical
cancer so like I look at people and I'm
like what are you carrying do you even
know what you have
oh that's to be on do you know it's
[ __ ] frightening yeah condoms man
who's caught there's so many people that
think just because they have HIV
medication out now but like nobody's
gonna catch anything but I'm like no
[ __ ] but if I was a dude I mean
because corn bother guys like so they
like all right no [ __ ] you you know
whatever I don't even know because of my
my dog I was asking him about HPV and
[ __ ] and then he was like it's mostly
all guys have it they just doesn't
affect them it doesn't and so like you
just don't know and a lot of girls have
it too but it's like a smaller
percentage of women who actually get
cervical cancer from it yeah a lot of
girls team they don't know it's such a
small percentage so it's like when it
happens it happens
yeah but it's psycho [ __ ] it's like if
you a lot of girls just walking around
with like the human pepper yeah
sometimes you don't have anything and
then sometimes you do yeah it's it's so
weird and sometimes you have know
sometimes it's why they call it the
secret killer it's like you know and
it's such a small percentage so it's
like every girl that I probably had sex
with either they had it or I had it and
you just don't know you don't know and
and your body can clear itself of it too
so that's what makes it even more
[ __ ] confusing it's just so weird
it's it's it's so weird sexually
transmitted disease is such a weird one
I don't know I just look at all these
guys and I know that they [ __ ] a lot of
like that's why I probably am like and
then I found out even like this I was
just talking to yes I said what about
hurt because dude there's so many people
the herpes Eaters don't even know
there's ninety percent of population
yeah it's ridiculous and so he was like
when people come and they freak out to
me about herpes he goes it's ridiculous
it's not gonna kill you yeah it's not
it's like the word is like the
percentage is so [ __ ] high you have
no idea so if you have it like a lot of
people don't show it but they have it so
don't even bring that up to me because I
hate it when people come in and they
freak out about it
come on yeah as a doctor he gets sick of
hearing it like he'll just give you
valtrex [ __ ] you'll be fine because I
get cold sores yes I've had coal sore
since I was a kid yeah you know cuz
cream people they share food a lot so
I've got probably gotten from somebody
else yeah yeah and then I was like and I
didn't know about [ __ ] the the the
medication that you could have a sickle
for yeah I don't know about that [ __ ]
and so because I've had cultures I don't
get a lot of that gave it like maybe
once every like three or four years
depending if I'm really sick of my
immune systems down yeah you don't get
enough sleep yeah and so because when
Asian people have it they just call it
fever blisters like oh you're a little
tired yeah they don't make a big deal
about it yeah in the United States think
you have [ __ ] herpes I was like oh
this is it's not that big of a deal
literally ninety percent if you guys get
cold force and you get Valtra sore that
Val sick Lavar which is the the
medication for it
that [ __ ] clears up like that and Abreva
you can put that on your cold sore and
you if
you take lysine daily super lysine helps
out all that helps with your immune
system like my buddy's a doctor and I
was like yo I got a coleslaw he goes do
you take like Val sick lavoro I was like
what's that he goes bro like just take
that [ __ ] and it goes away and I took it
and it was showing and it disappeared in
a day I was like I'm surprised you don't
take it like regularly I can but it
doesn't happen it doesn't happen a lot
so he goes like how often do you get him
like I don't know like the last time I
had it was like 30 years ago the little
blue pill that's not viagra yeah I was
like oh what the [ __ ] and I had no idea
about that [ __ ] I was like well I know I
could get rid of my coleslaw with that
[ __ ] game-changer that [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah game change it's a weird stigma
about it I didn't know it's an American
state but but not a big Asian stigma it
shouldn't be a stigma I'm glad that
you're talking about it to take away the
stigma you know honestly yeah and a lot
of people have [ __ ] cold sores and
they just like try to hide it it's like
if you're Asian like no Asian people
care about this [ __ ] I mean nobody
should care about it in general but I
want to tell you something
the only reason I grabbed my phone it's
because my valet always turn up ten and
it's past ten and I hope I'm not trapped
in Pasadena no you won't be
you know the belly is not part it's not
parking in the in the thing right just a
lay out front
oh yeah the guy was like when he got my
keys like how long are you gonna be I
was like okay well let me just wrap the
show okay well this expert cast because
the valet but that was a dope [ __ ] I'm
sorry like that but I'm like I hope I'm
not trapped know you'll see me in since
podcast but you guys keep this this this
episode of the genius brain podcast you
can catch us on iTunes stitcher any
audio platform leaving the comments
below
more stuff that you want to see from Sid
plug your stuff yes please go check out
Girl Interrupted it is my pod child make
sure to subscribe if you want to see
exclusive content go check out girl
interrupts its patreon and if you want
to follow me you can follow me at Syd
Wilder on Instagram or follow Girl
Interrupted on Instagram as well I love
you thank you if you love any of our
stories here you guys should already
know her podcasts gonna be [ __ ] crazy
although we went from sex weight we went
from depression me not being able to
pronounce EMDR to my depressing stories
to sex to groupies it takes time to warm
up that's all next time peace